resolvamos el inciso b encuentra la
magnitud de la aceleración del bloque 2
expresa tu respuesta en términos de m1
m2 y g y como siempre los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
esto por su cuenta ya resolvimos el
inciso a de este problema usando este
diagrama de aquí en el vídeo anterior y
ahora resolveremos el inciso b ya
dibujamos el diagrama de cuerpo libre lo
que nos ayudará para encontrar la
magnitud de la aceleración del bloque 2
primero pensemos que es la aceleración
sabemos que el bloque 2 se va a acelerar
hacia abajo porque el peso del bloque 2
es mayor que el peso del bloque 1 con el
que está conectado mediante una cuerda y
todo se va a acelerar hacia abajo el
lado derecho y hacia arriba el lado
izquierdo otra forma en la que podemos
pensar en ello es que el peso del bloque
2 es más grande que la fuerza de tensión
que va hacia arriba y el peso del bloque
1 es menor que la tensión que jala hacia
arriba
por lo que se acelera hacia arriba el
lado izquierdo y se acelera hacia abajo
del lado derecho aquí la idea clave es
darnos cuenta de que la magnitud de la
aceleración es la misma ya que ambos
bloques están conectados por la misma
cuerda
voy a dibujar la aceleración un poco
alejada del punto real la aceleración
aquí tiene una magnitud a con dirección
hacia abajo y la aceleración del lado
izquierdo tiene la misma magnitud pero
va hacia arriba
todo esto nos sirve para darnos una idea
de cómo funcionan las cosas nos dice
encuentra la magnitud de la aceleración
del bloque 2
este es el bloque 2 aquí arriba nosotros
sabemos que por la segunda ley de newton
si elegimos alguna dirección y de hecho
vemos que la única dirección que importa
es la vertical pues es la dirección en
la que todas nuestras fuerzas están
actuando hacia arriba o hacia abajo así
que la magnitud de la fuerza neta en la
dimensión vertical va a ser igual a la
masa m multiplicada por la aceleración
en esta dirección ahora pensemos en el
bloque 2 sabemos que su aceleración va
hacia abajo y queremos calcular qué es
supongamos que las magnitudes positivas
son las que tienen la dirección hacia
abajo cuáles son las fuerzas netas las
fuerzas netas serán la del peso hacia
abajo menos la fuerza de tensión que va
hacia arriba la dirección hacia abajo es
positiva así que tenemos m2 por g que es
el peso menos la atención que va contra
el peso y esto va a ser igual a la masa
2 multiplicada por la aceleración que es
lo que queremos conocer podría dividir
ambos lados entre m2 pero no nos va a
ayudar mucho en este momento porque
queremos dejar la aceleración en
términos de m2 g&t aquí no tenemos m 1
por lo que no despejamos en términos de
m1 m2 g&t sino sólo en términos de m2
g&t y de alguna manera tenemos que
deshacernos de esta t y lo que podemos
hacer para quitarla es establecer una
ecuación similar para el bloque 1
aquí nos interesan las magnitudes en
especial la de la aceleración aquí la
aceleración va hacia arriba podemos
decir que la dirección hacia arriba es
positiva entonces decimos que t -
sabemos que la atención es más grande
que el peso t - m 1 g va a ser igual a m
1 por la magnitud de la aceleración a y
recordamos que esas magnitudes son
iguales también sabemos que la magnitud
de la atención es la misma ahora tenemos
dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas de
manera que podemos eliminar la atención
y despejar la aceleración y lo podemos
hacer sumando el lado derecho con el
lado derecho y el lado izquierdo con el
lado izquierdo seguro aprendieron esto
en el primer curso de álgebra si esto es
igual a esto y esto es igual a esto otro
si sumamos el lado izquierdo con el lado
izquierdo y el lado derecho con el lado
derecho vamos a seguir teniendo dos
cosas que son iguales entre sí cuando
sumamos el lado izquierdo nos da
m2 por g - m 1 por g y luego vamos a
tener t - de estas se cancelan lo que es
conveniente esto va a ser igual a m2 a
más m 1 a y ahora nos falta despejar a
cómo lo hacemos vamos a factorizar la de
aquí tenemos m2 g - m 1 g iguala a que
multiplica a m2 más m 1 y ahora dividido
todo entre m2 más m 1 lo hago aquí m2
más m 1 y aquí también m2 más m 1 y nos
queda que a es igual a m2 g - m 1 g / m2
más m 1 por lo que despejamos a y la
dejamos en términos de m1 m2 y g y esta
es la magnitud de la aceleración tanto
para el bloque 1 como para el bloque 2
quizá alguno de ustedes esté pensando
que debe haber una forma más sencilla de
hacer
esto yo lo hice usando directamente el
diagrama de cuerpo libre porque está
implícito que esta es la forma de
resolver el problema usando la atención
pero otra forma de resolver el problema
es que podríamos decir que esto es
análogo aunque no es idéntico pero si es
análogo a tener estos dos bloques
flotando en el espacio aquí tenemos a m2
aquí no voy a dibujar las poleas aquí
tengo mi cuerda sin masa que está unida
a m2m uno que tiene una masa más pequeña
y digamos que jalamos esto a la derecha
ahora estamos flotando en el espacio
jalamos con una fuerza de m2 porque aquí
sólo nos interesan las magnitudes así
que no se preocupen por que esto sea el
campo gravitacional o su dirección
entonces estamos jalando esto con una
fuerza que resulta tiene una magnitud de
m2 por g ahora digamos que jalamos desde
este otro lado con una fuerza que tiene
una magnitud
m 1 porque esto no es exactamente igual
a lo que teníamos al principio si se
fijan lo que acabo de dibujar se parece
un poco aunque además teníamos la
presencia del campo gravitacional y
también un par de poleas el campo
gravitacional es el que proporciona
estas fuerzas pero ahora simplificamos
todo diciendo que está todo flotando en
el espacio y jalamos hacia la derecha
con una fuerza de m2 porque al mismo
tiempo que jalamos hacia la izquierda
con una fuerza de magnitud m 1 g podemos
ver a m 1 la cuerda y m2 como una masa
combinada m 1 + m2 y a esta masa
combinada la vamos a jalar hacia la
derecha con una fuerza de m2 por g y al
mismo tiempo la voy a jalar hacia la
izquierda con una fuerza de magnitud m 1
g y ahora tenemos algo bastante directo
cuál será la aceleración aquí podemos
decir que la magnitud de la fuerza en
eta será m2 por g tomamos la dirección a
la derecha como
positiva - m 1 g esta es la fuerza neta
con dirección hacia la derecha la
magnitud de la fuerza neta hacia la
derecha y la dividimos entre la masa y
vamos a tener la aceleración la fuerza
dividida entre la masa nos da la
aceleración pueden ver esto como una
versión más simple de esto pero
cualquiera de estos procedimientos nos
dará la misma respuesta esto es lo
divertido de la ciencia siempre y cuando
hagamos bien las cosas usando diferentes
estrategias llegaremos a la misma
respuesta